[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
francia como el resto de la unión
europea enfrentan ahora una segunda ola
de la pandemia de la cob y 19 esta
pandemia que desde su aparición hace 10
meses ha provocado ya la muerte de más
de 280.000 personas en europa de ellos
cerca de 40 mil aquí en francia a
distancia y en razón de las medidas
sanitarias que impone esta crisis este
virus
estamos saludando al doctor enrique
casalino director médico del grupo
hospitalario universitario de parís y
director de urgencias del hospital villa
una institución de referencia en materia
de enfermedades infecciosas de parís
doctor gracias por aceptar esta
invitación a escala en parís
bienvenido doctor el pasado 30 de
octubre el presidente emmanuel macrón
anunció a los franceses su decisión de
reconfirmar a la población francesa para
evitar dijo que el virus siguiera
circulando tan rápidamente apenas ayer
el director general de salud de francia
ha calificado esta segunda ola como
una situación de brutal cuál es su
apreciación a este respecto es verdad
que la situación en los hospitales está
sumamente tensa
a demanda de camas de hospitalización y
sobre todo de cama de hospitalización de
dos intensivos ha aumentado muchísimo en
estos últimos días ya sentíamos la
presión desde hace varias semanas pero
en estos últimos días ha habido un
aumento muy rápido de la curva de
aumento del número de casos y eso ha
hecho que la situación en el hospital
sea mucho más tensa mucho magnifica el
gobierno reconoce estar sorprendido
justamente por la velocidad y por la
magnitud de los contagios de estas
últimas semanas uno de los responsables
ha señalado que lo peor está por venir y
que eso peor se puede esperar de aquí a
diez días su apreciación
todos los modelos matemáticos porque
tenemos que basarnos en esos modelos
matemáticos todos los modelos
matemáticos que han sido validados en
otras epidemias y que han sido validados
en la primera hora de la epidemia tanto
en en francia como en españa en eeuu en
todos los países muestran que hay una
excelente capacidad de predicción el
número de casos y del número de casos
que vamos a recibir en cuidados
intensivos en los días que vienen todas
esas curvas muestran que a mediados de
noviembre deberíamos alcanzar el punto
más alto de la curva a condición por
supuesto de que respetemos las reglas de
distancia acción y el confinamiento que
han sido dictados ahora porque si no la
epidemia podría continuar pero doctor
usted decíamos es el director del
sistema de urgencias en el hospital
villa pueden escribirnos de una manera
breve cuál es un día en los sistemas de
urgencias en el hospital que del cual es
usted responsable en el sistema de
urgencias
nuestros grupos salario tiene más de 37
hospitales y en el grupo hospitalario de
que yo tengo la responsabilidad tenemos
7 hospitales en todos los hospitales los
servicios de emergencia reciben todos
los pacientes que tienen una suscripción
con estos puestos sientes una sospecha
de artículo en el campo en algunos casos
estos pacientes tienen una forma que no
es grave y se manejan de manera
ambulatoria en otros casos
desgraciadamente necesitan oxígeno y hay
que ocuparse de ellos desde las
emergencias eso es un problema mayor
porque son sumamente consumidores de
personal de salud y es lo mismo en el
momento que necesitamos hospitalizados o
que vayan a cuidados intensivos el
problema principal para que todos
nuestros auditores ofrenda es que si yo
pongo una enfermera para 10 pacientes en
una sala de hospitalización normal
necesito poner dos o tres enfermeras
para esos mismos diez pacientes cuando
los pacientes tienen corts en cuidados
intensivos
una enfermera para tres pacientes
tenemos que poner tres enfermeras para
tres pacientes cuando se trata de
pacientes con jueves lo que quiere decir
que el hospital tiene que ser anunciada
con número de camas tienes que cerrar un
cierto número de posibilidades de
atención en ambulatorio para poder
reorientar todo ese personal hacia los
pacientes componen eso reduce mucho la
capacidad del hospital a recibir
pacientes que no tienen con que les
recuerdo que si usted es un infarto es
un derecho absoluto de poder ser
recibido ha dejado y tratado
correctamente en el hospital y esa es la
preocupación principal cómo hacemos para
seguir válvulas todos los pacientes con
fobias y seguir garantizando la
detención de todos los pacientes que no
tienen cobis pero que tienen un problema
de salud de un infarto porque tienen una
embolia por lo que tienen un dolor o que
tienen un accidente de tránsito un
traumatismo tenemos que seguir
ocupándonos de todos los pacientes de
todos los casos
quiero recordar que el primer muerto por
19 aquí en francia se registró a
mediados de febrero pasado
de entonces para acá se han registrado
casi ya 40 mil muertos hace unos días el
primer ministro jan castex dijo que hay
un muerto en francia cada cuatro minutos
y una contaminación se produce cada 30
segundos son cifras terribles
ante esta situación me pregunta enrique
casal y no es las medidas que ha dictado
el gobierno recientemente de
confinamiento parcial son suficientes o
hay que ir más lejos
ha habido una discusión sumamente
importante que es una discusión entre
médicos epidemiólogos infectólogos los
emergencistas los intensivistas los
directores de hospitales todo el sistema
de salud reclama medidas que permitan ir
rápidamente y de manera sumamente eficaz
bloquear la transmisión del virus para
que el sistema de salud pueda seguir
garantizando el conjunto de sus visiones
de otro lado la discusión económica no
sé cuando nos dicen hay que mantener el
sistema económico porque la miseria
podría causar tantas muertes o más
alcohol y es verdad que si hubiese una
catástrofe económica eso podría tener un
impacto sobre el sistema sanitario y
además sub debate filosófico pero hay
algunos filósofos y pensadores gente muy
cultivada juristas abogados y discuten
sobre la realidad y la autoridad moral
en un estado y el derecho jurídico de
poder imponer este tipo de medidas y
confinar a las personas y limitar sus
vemos que se manejan muchas variables al
mismo tiempo como médico como
responsable en un sistema de salud
por supuesto que pienso que la medida
que han sido dadas hasta ahora no han
sido probablemente los suficiente
ambiciosas y hubiéramos podido quiz
hemos podido poner un poco más de
hincapié en la limitación de la
movilidad de las personas para obtener
rápidamente una disminución y no
encontrarnos en los días que vienen en
una bici sumamente grave en los
hospitales
voy a volver sobre esta temática si
usted me lo permite antes doctor
quisiera preguntar una cosa que también
es importante para nuestro público esto
usted viajó hace pocos días a perú es
originario de ese país y viajó para
instalar hospitales de urgencia yo
recuerdo que perú es uno de los países
de américa latina lamentablemente donde
se han registrado más casos de
contaminación qué es lo que ha podido
observar allá cuál es la situación
actualmente en ese país hay una
diferencia muy interesante entre lo que
ha pasado en el perú lo que ha pasado en
francia en francia tuvimos una primera
ola que ha sido una ola
intensa y que rápidamente disminuyó
porque el confinamiento fue sumamente
severo durante dos meses y hemos tenido
un periodo estival todo el verano en que
él prácticamente no ha habido con
terminaciones o muy poco la circulación
viral era muy baja en el perú ha habido
una primera ola pero que se transformó
en una situación crónica y hemos tenido
en el perú si usted hace un cálculo
desde febrero hasta ahora ocho meses
ocho meses con una epidemia permanente o
una ola no ha sido una ola sino un tumbo
como una especie de la marea ha subido y
hemos tenido durante ocho meses en el
perú una frecuencia alta e importante en
el número de casos en francia 5% de la
población ha sido con contaminada que es
30 por ciento de acuerdo si me gusta la
diferencia entre el número de casos que
se diagnostican y el número de casos que
finalmente realmente han habido en el
perú han sido probablemente 25 a 30 por
ciento de la población que ha estado en
contacto
acá en francia solamente 5 % hasta a
mediados del mes de julio me guste la
diferencia entre una hora y un plato y
ha durado durante meses eso es porque el
en el perú se favoreció en una un
sistema económico porque la población o
se moría del comido seguridad de hambre
porque no había posibilidad de trabajar
en francia el gobierno actualmente está
haciendo la misma apuesta que ha sido
hecha en el perú ya no estamos en una
lógica de ratificación final estamos en
una lógica digamos de tolerancia de una
circulación viral permanente y eso va a
ser que vamos a tener probablemente los
mismos 30 mil muertos estuvimos en la
primera bola lo vamos a hacer durante
los 6 meses que vienen hasta que termine
limpiado y algo como una ola enorme pero
como una marea que sube y que vamos a
tener durante meses un poco más un poco
menos en algunas regiones un poco más en
otras o menos pero vamos a tener en
permanencia un nivel de vino que circula
porque no podemos
el sistema económico a lo que se llama
hoy en día acá en francia una dictadura
sanitaria es es el término que se está
utilizando en francia esto le lleva a
una pregunta adicional
enrique casalino y es que justamente hay
un problema de medios si se produce esta
situación que usted comenta y es que los
hospitales públicos según entiendo a
decir de las propias autoridades están a
punto de saturarse yo recuerdo que el
hospital que los hospital en los
hospitales el personal médico y
paramédico ha reclamado del gobierno
mayores recursos mayores camas mayor
personal de manera muy muy breve
se está respondiendo a esto o siguen
arrastrando usted decía cuánta gente se
requiere para un sistema de cuando la
gente llega a reanimación urgencia se
está cubriendo estas posibilidades de
que frente a esta ola se pueda responder
a esas personas por el momento yo pienso
que el sistema hospitalario público y
privado está respondiendo está pidiendo
gracias un poco al agua al sacrificio el
compromiso del personal de salud con sus
presidentes y la responsabilidad de todo
el personal de salud
eso ha sido eso es un elemento sumamente
importante fue muy importante de la
primera ola y sigue siéndolo ahora una
diferencia es que la primera hora duró
si usted hacer el cálculo de los 6-8
semanas si esta segunda hora dura menos
aunque sea menos intensa dura seis meses
la situación va a ser mucho más crítica
porque en algún momento al personal de
salud es humano que va a tener un nivel
de fatiga un nivel de broun neutro de
fatiga profesional y va a haber un
problema de ausencias en el trabajo como
se va produciendo en el perú como se ha
producido en muchos países porque el
personal se enferma se fatiga tiene
accidentes todo eso explica que el
sistema pueda tener algunas fallas
y la doctrina que se está aplicando
actualmente en francia es de permanencia
el nivel de salud de este garantizado el
nivel de atención esté garantizado y que
las medidas se puedan ir dando variando
en el tiempo para garantizar que los
hospitales y el sistema de salud puedan
responder pues esperamos que esta
respuesta llegue a tiempo disculpe usted
que la corte se nos acaba
lamentablemente el espacio llegamos al
final de esta escala en parís
agradecemos al doctor enrique casalino
director de urgencias del hospital villa
de parís su presencia en nuestros
estudios a distancia gracias doctor por
habernos dedicado su tiempo a esta
escala en parís a ustedes hasta una
próxima escala otra semana
[Música]